[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans
is far far greater than what divides us
this morning an er doctor reflects on
his own painful experiences with race
and his push for diversity in a sport
that he loves
dr omar amir is a former u.s olympic
water polo player
and among the first african americans to
represent our country in this sport
he wrote an essay sharing his story
about overcoming racism
to find success in the pool cbs this
morning saturday co-host dana jacobson
spoke with dr amir
about his work to promote inclusion and
understanding
take a deep breath in and hold it
out of his scrubs and in the pool at the
university of california irvine
er doctor omar ahmer is still fueled by
competition
his strength and speed made him stand
out as a student here in the 90s
amar recalls being a small guy with big
dreams
since i was seven or eight years old my
only dream in life was to be an olympian
he came to the campus on a swim
scholarship but wanted to try water polo
so armor asked the coach to give him a
shot
he laughed at me and i just got in the
water within five minutes one of the
seniors broke my nose
made me very well aware of where i was
at the coach was
in his uh most loving way was like you
know you're going to let this little
n-bomb
beat all of you guys and i wanted to
kill someone after that but i just
used that as more motivation to succeed
while armor was enraged by the slur he
fell
hard for the sport and tried to prove
his worth to the team
and himself you could look across the
pool and there was no one look like me
at one point my water polo coach told me
that dark-skinned people had
lighter bones and we'd be better at land
sports you know
in so many sports the great equalizer is
once you can play
no one cares about anything else not in
swimming and water polo
in 1996 he made the national team
despite enduring physical and emotional
intimidation
they just destroyed me in practice
just make it so miserable
that they'd hoped that i would quit i am
certain now that if i was white
none of this would have happened after
spending his undergraduate years
strengthening his body and mind
almer applied and was accepted to
harvard medical school
but he remained focused on his olympic
dream splitting his time between med
school and boston during the week
and water polo training some 3 000 miles
away in california on the weekends
armor made the 2004 team competing in
greece along with goalie janai kerr
the first two african americans to
represent the u.s
in the sport i remember turning over to
our goalie and being like
we're here wow i finally did it
did you enjoy it then i loved it i loved
it
last year as protesters filled the
streets demanding
social justice omer began to reflect on
how
his race and ethnicity impacted his life
he published an essay nearly every team
meal
included pork which as a muslim i could
not eat when i asked for different food
i was singled out and told it was this
or nothing
while armor was shunned by some for
speaking out the essay prompted a flood
of public speaking invitations he spoke
by zoom to employees at global marketing
firm in ocean
tim murphy is ceo i think it's really
opening up people's eyes
i want to make sure that all employees
understand
how how to treat people in the workplace
it was so impactful and so inspirational
i think that's really what people took
away
ashley johnson the first black woman on
the u.s
water polo roster will be tending goal
in japan
amer has coached and encouraged her
since she was a kid
it makes me want to fight harder it lets
me know that there's so much more change
that needs to happen in our sport so
your liver looks beautiful
no one ever looked at me and said oh
this guy is going to succeed they just
gave me a million reasons why i should
quit it was just
fuel to the fire for me i'm going to be
better and smarter
and stronger than all of these people
and someday they're going to give me
respect
the son of egyptian immigrants in his
essay alma writes
i am a dark-skinned curly-haired
southern californian
i am an american i do believe we have
the power to heal ourselves from the
poison of racism
[Music]
cbs this morning dana jacobson
huntington beach california
love everything about the doctor i mean
your heart goes out for the struggle
that he had
but also got to give a shout out to tim
murphy who saw that and said my
employees need to hear this
you know that's that's what i think all
this conversation is about that it will
touch someone in a way
that they will say you know what we need
to learn more about this right bravo
and he's turning the pain that he
experienced growing up in in this sport
into power to inspire
others and look at the you know the
athlete that they just highlighted who's
going to the olympics oh we're lucky in
many ways that he was as resilient as he
was
you know that he just kept going that's
true look at the stuff he had to take
yeah that shot where he's standing in
the picture and his head is hanging down
and everybody's looking that's pain
all right he made it yes he made it
doctor you made it